i guess it's i'm a bit nervous because i
was expecting a crowd of grad students
but i
i feel that i know quite a few of you
and so
i and you probably know much more than
uh on many of the topics i'd like to
discuss and
sorry my
face recognition
so um
so the topic is supposedly duality and
in fact i i did not select the title um
ben
ben did and in fact when he invited me
um he sent me this very nice email um
and inviting me to give a serious
reflection and he says on duality and
it's using combinator optimization
and we hope you could speak about min
max work characterization surrounding
and the themes that unite basic ids in
lp to modern frontiers in tsp extremely
well said
but then as i was preparing i felt oh i
should talk about this i should talk
about that i should talk about this and
then i ended up having like 15 lectures
or so and then i said oh no no that's
so um at the end i was struggling to
trying to focus on a few things so i'm
not going to
cover all these um
the plan is
to
what i'd like to do is i'd like to
illustrate some links between discrete
and and um continuous optimizations and
i keep it at the basic at a very basic
level so i apologize for um
three quarters of you or maybe even 99
percent of you
and
some of the themes that
i will try to develop is
the notion of a relaxation how to go
from a discrete optimization problem to
a continuous problem
duality
is going to be
also important and i will
start with some
some aspects of duality but not not so
much from a discrete optimization point
of view first i'll start from a
continuous
optimization point of view and then um i
will also talk about uh running schemes
in which you try to go from the
continuous
to a solution to a continuous
optimization problem back to
um the discrete
now
that's way too many things so um
what i'm going to try to do is a random
walk in
and on the bridge
over the bridge
on the bridge let's see
and uh so let me uh
start with a few very basic
things
so what is um
what's the beast of interest the beast
of interest is an optimization problem
and so we're trying to minimize
um
some objective function c of x
over
over x in s
sunset and
two
cases that are of interest to us one is
the discrete setting
in which
in which we could be optimizing over on
collections of sets we could be
optimizing overall permutations
we could have um
a graph and we could be interested in
sets of verses with certain properties
on sets of edges with certain properties
and c is often
um
c is often
linear i mean it's often a
linear function of the uh elements uh in
the set so um
so it could be um
and then on the other side we could also
have as um
continuous
and in that case what we would be
interested in is uh we'd like to have
some nice properties of s so of
continuity differentiability
uh if we want to be able to efficiently
solve this we'd like us to be convex for
example and um
or as could be
for example uh semi algebraic said and
and there will be some
talks about this during the week
and um cfx
would be
often um either convex some um maybe a
polynomial
uh maybe linear
so
the
the
one thing that's really
very important will be the notion of a
relaxation
and the reason that we're interested in
relaxations is that many of the problems
that arise in discrete optimization
like the traveling salesman problem the
stave on set problem and so on
are all
hard to solve i mean most of them are
hard to solve and so we'd like to be
able to transform them relax them into
our easing problem so instead of looking
at
minimizing
cx
over x in s
what we'd like to do is we'd like to go
to another problem uh minimizing g of x
let's say over
x in p
and we'd like to make sure that
this
gives us a
let's say a long bound on these values
so we'd like to impose this
and so one way to do it is for example
if we assume that
we are one optimizing over a larger set
so p contains s
and then also that
um
that if i restrict my function g of x to
the elements of x
then i get something that's
so i get c of x so g of x
is equal to c of x
all x
um
in
for all x and s
and so if if that's the case then
clearly we
have a long bound
now
some of the
so on goal is to have this problem to be
easier to solve than this one
and
and then we'll be able to we'll try to
go back from the
easing problem
to the original problem so among
so maybe for now i should
just uh
pop this
okay good thank you
um
so
so what are the properties some basic
properties of relaxations
is that
one of them is that if
if when we optimize over this problem so
if
so if we let
we get the
the optimum uh of g of x
over x in p if this solution f x star
belongs to us
then
um
then external is also
the minimum of the the problem of
interest to us so the arg min
over x in s of c of x
so and
how could we uh manage this for example
if we if we succeed in
if we succeed in
having p to be the convex of s
then in that case
and
and for example in the case in which c
of x is linear
then we know in that case that
the
we'll get an extreme point
the element that uh one going to get in
p
will be
um will be also an element in s and then
we have um equality in that case so
but these id is also
very much used in in cutting planes
in
integer programming
in which what what you do is you'd like
to optimize over a bunch of points
so ideally you'd like to optimize over
the the convex all of these points
um
but you may you may not know all the
inequalities
defining the convex cell so what you
might do is you might optimize over
a
larger set larger polygon set that
contains the convex cell then you
optimize you make at this point and then
you may try to find an inequality that's
violated like maybe this one
and you now optimize over these smaller
polygon set
and you continue you get let's say this
optimum and then you generate maybe this
inequality and now you can
by optimizing over this set
you would obtain this solution which is
a member of s
and so you get that um the solution that
you obtain is the optimum so that's uh
that's quite uh simple unfortunately um
typically
it's um
it's hard to
typically we would take p not to be the
convexel and have a a p that's actually
just a it contains the convex cell
usually but um may not be equal
so
what we could um
what but a nice property of a relaxation
is that if
if we can
somehow by some heuristic method find an
element uh in in s
so if
find
x in s
um
of a certain value and let's call it x
hat
and then i also solve optimally
these relaxed problems
um and so let's say x tau is the
argument
over p
of g of x
if that's the case and then if i can
relate the values so if
um
if
the value of x hat
is not too much more than
let's say alpha times the value of uh
of g of x x star
then what's nice is that i know that
then um
then i know that
uh c
c of x at
is at most
alpha times
um
the min
over x in s
of c of x
so that would give me a solution to my
original problem that's approximately
minimum so very simple uh very clear
now
what
if we have managed to
define a relaxation
that's
that's easier
we can expect to we can hope to be able
to rely on duality so duality is a nice
way of taking
an optimization problem that's
that's um
so g of x over x in p
and creating a new problem which is a
maximization problem
h of x
h of y let's say y and q
in such a way that
these two problems are related
in strong duality you'd like to have
equality between these problems
and
and the nice thing is that if you
have a dual problem to your relaxation
then what you can do is instead of
finding the optimum solution to
um to the relaxed problem what you can
do instead is only just so if
if this min is at most the max
or equal
um then
if you find an x in s
and a y
in
the door of your relaxed problem such
that c of x
is at most
alpha times h of
y tilde y a y hat
then you again
get the same uh same kind of relation
so
these are very basic things i'd like um
now to talk a bit about duality
um
but i i mean even though i love mid max
relations and duality for in the
discrete case i france would like to go
over duality in the in the continuous
case and and i think then the
the right notion of uh duality
um
duality
for the connection between discrete and
com and continuous optimization is the
notion of konig duality
so suppose
um
so suppose i have an optimization
problem
in which
i have a cone k
um
that's um i mean we need some technical
assumptions we need the cone to be
closed it's a convex cone
so any line segment is within the cone
uh it's easier if the cone has none
empty engineering and i'm assuming that
it lies let's say you could say in rn
and you have the you usual uh inner
product or you could even say you're in
an inner product space and you have
these inner product cx
and you just have the cone constraints
and then some linear constraints
so a typical case is
for example linear programming
in which
um
the cone is just the non-negative on
tint
and then you impose that
x belongs to the non-negative
non-negative one so it's not negative
and you have these linear constraints
and you minimize
but then you can you can
look at different kinds of cones and
different kinds of optimization problem
so if you look at for example
um within the set of symmetric matrices
you look at
the
matrices that are positive semi-definite
and i'll define that in a second
then you get the notion of
a semi-definite programming
um these are two examples but you could
you could imagine even
even some completely combinatorial
objects so for example you could look at
the cut cone and what is the cut cone
is simply you take um
in the cut cone
you take a graph on uh environment
series let's say the complete graph and
then francis and then
for every set s
of vern seas so the the vontex set is
the
elements from one to n
you look at
delta s
which are all the edges so you have s
you have the complement of s
and you look at all the edges
across so delta s is the set of
i
j in
the parenthesis such that
i j intersect s
as cardinality one
and then you can look at
you can look at the
the cone
generated by
the incidence vectors on these cuts so
you can define cut off n
it's just a set of
non-negative
linear combinations
on these cuts as subset of
n
such that lambda s is not negative
or less
so
i have my incidence vectors of all my
cuts i look at the cone generated the
cone generated by all these so that
could be that could be my uh
my cone
and then i would then optimize overall
cone intersected by linear equalities
so
no one calls that cut cone programming
but you could
have the special a second order cone
also known as ice cream cone that also
fits nicely
but then you can look at for example
if
if you
look at
complex matrices you can look at complex
summation positive semi-definite
matrices and that would lead to complex
semi-definite programming
or in fact i mean my favorite one and uh
and what you uh from people who
will be here for a long time they
definitely need to talk to uh
uh jim and pablo uh who
um
probably love this cone even more than i
do but i
um so if i have time i might
um discuss hyperbolic cones a bit
um
so
so now
how can we define duality
uh from this cone programming so
the the right notion is to look at these
uh dual cone and so it's we look at
all the elements
that have a non-negative inner product
from with all elements in key
and
question is what is that keystrong
so you can
firstly easily see that the basic
assumptions i had on the code means that
actually if i take the dual of the duo i
get the the original cone that's easy to
see it's also easy to see that if k is
finitely generated you have a finite
number of
of elements that generate your cone then
you can
easily say them should be greater than
or equal to zero i'm not going to write
on the screen but this should be greater
than or equal to zero
for all i
and there should be a brace as well
um
and for example if you take if you take
the co the
non-negative on
then you immediately see that that's
equal um to its drone so it's self dual
and in fact there are quite a few
um
cones that are the focus in uh in
continuous optimization that are
self-double so the non-negativity often
the second one cone the psd code psd
over
complex submission matrices so these are
all um
but in general it's hard to
to get a handle of what is the doom so
for example in the case of the cut cone
it's actually not easy to describe
k-stone
because even though it's finitely
generated and you know all the
um you know all the generators these are
all the cuts
the problem is that to get a description
um
the the dual you can get a description
in terms of uh inequalities but what's
not obvious is what are the extreme ways
of of that cone
yeah
is the definition making sense for any
inner product versions for the standard
product no you can take any inner
product so yeah so it's it's very very
general so for example in the case of
positive semi-definite matrices you can
use the uh for being your inner product
and
just to remind them if you
if
linear algebra was a long time ago um
[Music]
so
a matrix is positive semi-definite
a symmetric matrix is positive
semi-definite
um if that quadratic form is not
negative or equivalently you could say
um
the eigenvalues on a negative or you
could say that it can be factorized as v
transpose v for some
matrix v
so that's the grand decomposition
or you can express a in terms of a sum
of non-negative
non-negative rank one
matrices
so the the cone of uh
positive semi-definite matrix um
it's an extreme race on one matrices and
the nice thing is that it's it's uh it's
dual
is also this the same cone of positive
semi-definite matrices let's quickly see
that it's elementary but let's uh
let's quickly um
show that
so
take
so first of all
let me take a an x
which is in the
forum so it has to be that's to have a
non-negativity in a pro non-negative
inner product with every y so in
particular it means that x times y y
transpose is not negative
for every y
but that means that
y transpose x y is not negative which
means that x is positive semi-definite
so that implies
x is pst
similarly if x is psd
um
then
if x is
psd
then i know that
i know that x can be expressed for
example as sum of lambda i
s i s i transpose or v i v i transpose
these are the eigenvectors and these are
the non-negative eigenvalues and so now
if i take
x
inner product with y for any positive
semi-definite y
then i get that
this is equal to
the
inner product of
sum over i y i s i s i transpose times y
and so this is
uh this is greater or equal to 0 because
this is the sum over i of lambda i times
uh
this quadratic form which is not
negative because y is positive
semi-definite so that means that
x also belongs to them
so it's self
self uh
um
and
and so that's if you look at that koenig
program you get um what's known as
semi-definite programming so you impose
that the
your variables are the
the entries of a symmetric matrix and
you impose that that matrix is positive
semi-definite you impose linear
constraints and you
minimize or max
minimize a linear objective function
so one thing is that it's not minimized
but it's the infimum because the minimum
is not necessarily attained so
as opposed to
linear programming in which it's always
attained
now um
this is the
most important slide of the the first
part of this talk so it's the
duality of cones so it's
quite simple so if i give you a konic
program
from some
cone k
then you can write the dual in the
following way
you
you look at
so this is a linear map so you can look
at the adjoint
map so such that this
is satisfied so that's also going to be
a linear map and you get that
you'd like to impose that c
minus
this element is in the dual cone and
you'd like to find the supremum of this
linear functional and then you you the
claim is that you get with duality so
let's look at weak duality why is this
at least that when x satisfies this and
y satisfies that it's very simple z
minus w is cx minus yb so it's cx minus
for b i can replace it by ax
and now i can rearrange it i can say
that this is
a standard y times x so that's c minus s
times y times x and now and that's the
key i have an element of k and element
of the dual and so that's not negative
by definition
now
in fact
for any cone if you want to take the cut
cone or if you anything you always have
strong duality
so
you need some regularity assumption and
i can discuss that in a second but until
some assumption you get that z is equal
to w so the infimum here
is equal to the supremum
um
and they are attained and so what is
that regularity assumption
you can do it in several ways one way is
to assume that
they exist
so remember i assume that k
and k
um
at the non-empty interior
so we can assume if we assume that there
exists a strictly feasible solution so a
solution in the internal of k that
satisfies this and also a solution
y that's in the internal of k strong
then in that case you have strong
duality
you always have weak duality and you
need his assumption or you need
something similar to have strong duality
why is that enough
to get strong duality so strong duality
is nothing complicated so let's quickly
uh argue it
so
let's let's assume for example i have a
internal
that's for now i assume just an internal
dual feasible solution
so if i have an internal dual feasible
solution
what i could do is i could look at
um
so if i have a um
if i have a strictly
um so if i have a y
such that c minus
is on y
hat let's say
is in the interior of keystone
what i can do is
i can first look at
the set of x in the primal
such that
its value
is um
x in
so x satisfying the primal conditions
such that c x is at most some value v
so one can easily show that this is all
this is assuming this this is bounded
and this follows uh
easily i'm not sure i'll be able to do
it on the blackboard but we can try
doesn't uh
doesn't cost much to try
uh even when it's on uh
video and being recorded but that's okay
so
um
so what is uh
what is cx
well um
what is uh cx
so
um
maybe i'll look at my
notes might be a better
idea
so should i
start it this way
find my notes
so let me
let me start
from the door so i take
that strictly into solution
and let me
take the inner product with x
so what is this that's cx
minus
this times that and so i can rewrite
that as
y hat times a of x
but if x is feasible if x is feasible so
x in k and
ax
is equal to b
if x is feasible this is b so that's c x
minus
y at b
and so now that means that if i assume
that c x is at most v
i get that
this
is a compounded
by some number
and
um but this
it's in the interior
of keystone so there is a small ball
around it
that's still within k a k stone so that
means that
x
will be bounded so the intersection with
k will be bounded so that means that so
if i take if if i look at the wages of a
small ball x will be in the radius of a
ball that's inversely
that times this so x is uh so this is
bounded
so if it is bounded the infimum
is attained and so that's a minimum
now that you have a minimum
i feel so bad doing this in front of
all these experts but that's okay um
so if if um if that's attained then in
terms of the supremum
you can easily use the separating hyphen
plane
to show that
you look at
you look you'd like to find a
y that achieves the value of the optimum
so you'd like to
get
so i told you
i told you that the primal is achieved
so that's the optimum
value for the primal
and now i'd like to find a y
such that yb
is equal to
cx stone
so for that what i'm going to do is
i'm going to try to um
but again what is y b y b is
y times
um
a x
so this is y
uh this is uh a stan y
times x
and so i'd like to find um
i'd like to find a y
such that
this inner product
is equal to that inner product
so what i'm going to do is um to use my
separating hyperplane
result from convex from convex analysis
what i'm going to look is i'm going to
look at the space
of
a star y
over all possible y's
and then i'd like that to be
in
in case in c minus k star so i have c
minus k star
if i can find a point that's in both
then then i'm done uh but if not there
exists a separating hyphen plane and
that separating hypoplane has to be
orthogonal to this space so that
i get a z
such that
i get a z
such that
for every
element
in
so i get that z
at that c
minus any element of k star
times z is strictly less than zero
whatever i put here in k star
so that means that um
that means two things it means first
that
means that c z
is less than zero and it also means that
um
z times k star is going to be
um and i have also that
z times k star is going to be
non-negative for all y
in k-stone
that means that z is in k
so that's z is in k
and c z is less than zero which means
that if i take my
if i take my optimum x term
if i take my optimum external and then
from that optimum external i go in the
direction z
i will stay feasible because
this is linear
and
a z
is zero
so i'll stay feasible from the
constraints i'll stay in k because z is
in k
but i'm going to improve the objective
function because c z is less than zero
so it's unbounded so that's the
classical i mean i apologize for 99 of
the
of the audience but
that's the basic
um
duality um
convex optimization and uh specialized
to uh cones um
okay so let's go back to sdp for a
second
michelle yeah before we do could you go
back two sides
so what what happened though actually i
just want to see the example where the
if is not a tent
that guy okay
so you can i mean so if you don't if if
you don't have this
so
if you uh
so if you don't have this anything can
break loose in the sense that the primal
may not be attained the dual may not be
attained and even
once than that the female value might
not be equal to the supremium value if
we go back to this one
i did copy it down right so the problem
with that one so that has it that
satisfies slater in the primal but the
dual ends right exactly so you'll have
strong duality
but um
but you will not both the primal and the
duo will not be attained so only one of
them
now
so just to go back to sdp
um
so that's just the the primal and the
duo so if you have a strictly feasible
solution here and a strictly feasible
solution there then you have the
infisame in and the soup is the max and
you have equality
now one thing i'd like to insist which
which uh is is really cool is the fact
that
um
at up at uh at optimality you have
actually more than
just uh
so at optimality you know that
c at optimality
you know that cx is equal to that and
when you rewrite that it means that
the
x times s
and that's the slack matrix that that's
a
zero in a product
now the nice thing about um
about these cones is that this actually
implies a much stronger condition so
just having a zero inner product implies
that actually the the usual matrix
product of x and s
is that's the zero matrix
and so
um so that's one used to that i mean if
if if you're on the discrete side you
are used to that in in for linear
programming um but it actually carries
through
um to monogeneral optimization convex
optimization problems so in linear
programming when you have the slack
times your primal solution is zero and
both on a negative then you immediately
imply that each
component x i s i zero same thing here
and again it's obvious so
um
i like to do easy proof so that it's
so let's see why this implies that
so
suppose i have
s times x
is equal to zero
so what do i know um
i know that s is positive semi-definite
and x is positive semi-definite let's
take france as positive semi-definite so
i can decompose it into
let's say sum of uh
lambda i
s i s i transpose
and so times x lambda i are non-negative
and i are not negative so this is equal
to the sum over i lambda i which on a
negative
times s i s i transpose times x
times x but x is positive semi-definite
so let me instead write it as v times v
transpose
so
what is this that is the same thing as s
i
s i v
s i transpose v v transpose s i
and so
um so this is the square of this guy
so this is the same thing as
that's ground and so i get that this is
equal to the sum over i of lambda i
times this but this is not negative and
this is not negative
so all of them have to be zero so that
means
that in particular v transposes i is
equal to zero for every i but if this is
true
then
you get that v v transpose s i
is equal to zero
and so that means
xsi
is equal to 0 but if xsi is equal to 0
it means that
when i take the regular product of s
times x
which is equal to the sum over i of
lambda i s i s i transpose
times x
this is equal to
um
since g's will be 0 i get 0.
so very simple it's not not doing
i'm just
i mean these are just from the purely
discreet people
uh that have not
played with this uh
in
decades so
um
now let me switch gears a bit um
and let me
um
go back to the
discrete
and uh remember what i told you
if so here is a prototypical
discrete optimization problem you are
given a graph and
you
say that a set of forces is stable or
independent
if between any
parents of them there is no edge
and the
basic question is what's the largest
number
of such
of such a stable set and that's denoted
by alpha g now alpha is uh known to bnp
hard and there are also some strong
results about in approximability of
alpha
but then there was a
um
an amazing
an amazing result by lova so i would say
that if you if you want to
leave from here and
and take some techno message first you
should talk to first message was you
should talk to pablo and jim about
hyperbolic optimization
and
read for example jim's paper on it
and the second thing is uh you should go
and read lovas and maybe that's even
before uh i'm sorry apologies to
jim and pablo you should go and read
lova79 that's the it's an amazing people
um
and
it's um
so what he did was that he defined
um he defined an upper bound so in this
case we're maximizing
so
when we relax we'd like to get a an
upper bound on the optimum so we defined
an upper bound theta that has many
different ways of being uh being
formulated so
it can be stated as an eigenvalue bound
as a semi-definite program in terms of
normal representations and so on let me
discuss the
one of the many semi-definite
programming formulation
so
when i
told you initially while you
you'd like
when you look at the relaxation you
optimize over s and you optimize over p
and i said you'd like p
to contain s well in fact i mean what
you really want
is you want a map
you want a map from
s to p
and then you'd like to make sure that if
i take that if i look at the evaluate
the value
of
pi of x
this is g is this is c of x
for any x in s
so in this case what i'd like is i'd
like to take any stable set
map it
to
so if i'd like to get a semi-definite
program i'd like to
map it to a matrix that's positive
semi-definite
and look at the properties of that
matrix
and um
and then
i'm going to take a login space that
contains all of
these so
in this case one of the
many maps that are possible is to take a
stable set
and then map it to the following matrix
in which
the matrix if this is s
so what you would do is you would put 0
all over the place
and here you would take a matrix that's
1 over s
times the matrix of all
all ones
so
that's one over s times the matrix of
all ones here
um
and so if you do that notice the
sum of the linear constraints that x has
to satisfy
so one of them is that if you look if
you look at the trace of that matrix
the trace of that matrix is
equal to one all the time i divided by
one over on the cardinality of s so
that's always equal to one
that matrix since it's a
rank
it's a rank one matrix
but it's a rank one matrix with a
non-negative coefficient so that's
positive semi-definite
now
since i know that
i don't have two valencies connected by
an edge
with an s so that means that
that means that actually i get that x i
j 0 if i j is an edge
and and then if i want to
see what is the size of my s so i'd like
to
compute
c of x so what i can do is i can just
look at my matrix x
and
multiply it by a matrix of all ones take
the uh
you know product with a matrix of all
ones and that will be my cardinality of
s so so my map in terms of values i will
evaluate the value of a positive
semi-definite matrix in terms of this
inner product
now all this is
nice that's my
that's a conic program
uh
over the positive semi-definite matrices
except for this one
so let me
so if i if i want to keep this
i would then have a bijection between s
and p and i would not lose anything but
but since i have to i have to relax this
if i'd like to get a
a nice chronic program or from positive
semi-definite matrices i will get an
upper bound on alpha and that's given by
these positive semi-definite the
semi-definite program in which i have
the semi-definite
programming
constraints plus the trace
the trace and these
okay
now
um
now
what's what's amazing about these
theta function
is
is that if you look at
a subclass of graphs so the class of
config graphs and what's the notion of a
class of graph is that
if i look at
if i look at the largest stable set
so clearly
nearly a stable set
and a clique so a clique is a complete
sub graph a stable set and a click can
have at most one vertex in common
so if i have a stable set
s and then i have a bunch of cliques
that govern all the vertices of my graph
then
each clique
can contain at most one vertex of my
stable set so this is a click that's a
click that's a click
but each click i use can contain at most
one vertex of my stable set and so the
the
the number of
the smallest number of cliques covering
all the valencies that's an upper bound
on the stable set
number so you for any graph
for any graph you have that alpha
so for any graph
for every g you have that alpha of g
is at most
um
these
smallest number of cliques covering all
valencies
now you define a graph to be perfect
if not only this is true you have
equality
but it's true also for every sub-graph
so for every sub-graph
of
if i look at the induced sub-graph g of
s
this must be equal to
um
to the
click covering number
so
there are lots of nice classes of
graphs which are perfect for example you
can take
bipactite graphs quantum graphs and so
on
a
an only nice result of lovas was to show
that if you have a graph that's perfect
its complement is also perfect and its
proof is is a purely polygon proof so
it's really a proof that goes into the
um
into
the continuous setting in fact
i should do that i'll do that after the
break then
after the eclipse now um
the
so the um
this
a
really uh long-standing open problem
which was resolved by chanovsky robinson
is actually a
is a characterization of the graphs
which are perfect so the graphs are
perfect if and only if
uh it has no cycle
of odd length with no coins and
similarly no compliment of that
also robin thomas
and i'm sorry yes
yes definitely should now ski robertson
seymour and thomas thank you
apologies
that's the problem when you do the
slides at the last minute
now
the amazing result of
low vas as well is the fact that uh from
perfect graph you have equality between
um
alpha of g and theta of g so you can
compute the largest table set in a graph
by
solving these semi-definite programs so
that's
as uh as ben was saying there is no gap
between discrete and continuous
optimization so that's that's the
the the nicest example of in my mind of
really using continuous optimization
uh for solving a deep question in uh
discrete optimization
so the largest table set can be found
efficiently using sdp
and um
that there was no combinatorial
so there was no yes so um
so in fact yeah so that's a so
in terms of the history so in 1979
love has published this amazing paper
that has it's only seven pages but just
describing all the results in it would
take probably five elections
so
um and so that's uh but at that time
uh semi-definite programming
was essentially inexistent
so in that seven-page paper he developed
duality developed everything
about semi-definite programming in fact
it's it's very much between the lines so
uh but it's very nicely done
and um
but then there was no algorithms for it
but then it was um then the ellipsoid
algorithm came out or at least it came
out in the west
and grocer lovers and scrivener noticed
that
you can actually
um
you can actually
solve this
in polynomial time up to
uh
an epsilon and since in the case of
confography of equality you know that
this will take only integer values from
config graphs and so you can actually go
from weak optimization to
uh strong optimization so so the
the fact that you can compute this in
polynomial time was first known when the
ellipsoid
ellipsoid algorithm came out and
its applications in discrete
optimization
were observed
later on
when the strong perfect graph theorem
was proved
by zhunovsky
sansimo and thomas
there was actually
um an algorithm for optimizing overhead
did not come with it so
one needed to do more work and there was
a subsequent paper
with a slightly different set of atoms
that shows that you can also use his
decomposition to do it in
efficiently
now one thing i'd like to
mention to connect to just in the one
minute that remains before we go see the
eclipse is the following
is that um if you look at um
let me define three
polytropes and convex sets in fact two
two polytropes and one convex set so the
phospholitope is
the convex sole of all stabili stable
sets in the graph
and then you could say you could say
well i know that a clique
intersects a stable setting at most one
vertex
so i could just look at these
these inequalities
and that's another
polito but it's a larger polytube than
the stable set that's not enough to
describe the stability so q stab of g is
a super set of step of g
but you don't have equality typically
and then you can put something in
between that's motivated by
this rank of lovas
and that's this semi-definite program so
you you have um you have a semi-definite
program defined on
on the matrix y
and it's a it's a matrix that's
n plus one rows by n plus one if n is
the size of the vertex set
and then you read from the first row
you read
the entries exabytes and that's going to
be
um an element that's in q-step it's
sandwiched between stav and q-stab
so that's what
don knuth called a sandwich theorem
now what's very nice is that in the case
when the graph is perfect you have
actually quality
everywhere in in this inclusion so
the st the stable set polytube is equal
to
uh
the theta body which is equal to
q stab of g
and um
and this is actually only no only true
from config graph so that's a
characterization of config graph g is
perfect if and only if you have equality
here
and similarly this theta body which is
this semi-definite program
is going to be polygon if and only if g
is perfect and one thing i would love to
see is actually
a
being able to check to decide if a graph
is perfect
by
doing it collegially on
proving or disproving that th of g is
political now the final thing i'd like
to say is that this is a unique example
of
a
polytope namely the stable set polytope
which we were able not we love us and
companies were able to
lift to a higher dimensional space
have a
then the define a um
one of these spectra agents or one of
these semi-definite uh constraints and
then projecting it down and get exactly
that
that polygon set so it's it's hard to
visualize because you would imagine that
if you if you take something that's
that's actually round and then you
project it
kind of you would assume it's not
polygon but so that's a an amazing
example of you'll see talks about
extended formulations uh later in the
week and and so this is an amazing
uh
such example so let me stop here
and we'll continue after the eclipse
[Applause]
you can ask the question and then i'll
respond afterwards